by the end of this financial year 18
million patients will have access to a
GP at mornings evenings and weekends by
the end of this Parliament I want that
for everyone and this seven-day NHS will
be just as vital in our hospitals to it
is a shocking fact but mortality rates
for patients admitted to hospital on a
Sunday can be sixteen percent higher
than on a Wednesday while the biggest
numbers of seriously ill patients arrive
at the weekend when hospitals are least
well equipped to handle them so seven
day care isn't just about a better
service for the patient it's also about
saving lives we simply can't aspire to
be the safest healthcare system in the
world without this commitment while our
hospitals are working hard Monday to
Friday to get patients better sometimes
it can feel as though saturdays and
sundays are more about just somehow
getting through to monday diary those
diseases don't work weekdays nine to
five and so neither can we when you SAT
through a night in a hospital watching a
loved one and praying for the morning
when you spend a weekend longing for the
week you know just how important these
changes really are so let's be
absolutely clear this is not about NHS
staff working seven days a week it's
about different shift patterns so that
our doctors and nurses are able to give
that incredible care whenever it's
needed it's about key decision-makers
being around at the weekend junior
doctors being properly supported and
crucially resources like scanners up and
running whenever they're needed now I
don't underestimate the scale of the
challenge in making all this happen but
just as we came together as a nation to
create the National Health Service
nearly 70 years ago so I believe that
together by sticking to the plan we can
become the first country in the world to
deliver a truly seven-day NHS and we
must do so to protect and preserve the
values of the NHS that are so central to
our national identity to keep our people
healthy to look after them when they
fall ill to care for the elderly with
dignity and to ensure that free health
care is always there whenever people
need it most